hello everyone and welcome to round five
of this year's fed Grand Swiss this is
the most recommended game from round
five it is arjon Nasi versus Arena
jumabay Grandmaster from Kazakhstan
we've had him on the channel quite a few
times and it's a really complicated game
I could have chosen maybe even seven
pause the video moments I decided for
two uh and I think you guys will really
enjoy them so let's check it out Arjun
has the wi pieces and he opens with Pawn
to E4 we have Pawn to E5 by reat Knight
to F3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5
D Lopez is on the board Knight to F6 and
now D3 countering the Berlin defense
this way we have Bishop to C5 and now
Pawn to C3 and here castles and the D6
are the standard way of handling this
but here we have the immediate D5 and
it's something that um uh is very
standard when your opponent plays Pawn
to C3 as now the Knight cannot come to
C3 you are not afraid to bring your
queen out early in the center of the
board and okay we have e captures on D5
Queen captures and now Bishop to C4
attacking the queen This Way Queen to D6
and now Pawn to B4 immediately expanding
on the queen side Bishop to B6 and now
Knight B to D2 and the position has been
seen before we've seen moves like
castles in this position also Bishop to
F5 was played in this position for
example uh Carana headed against leevon
Aron he defeated Leon also an burish
headed against Yuri karko B defeated
karko in this position but here we have
Bishop to G4 uh and it is now as of move
nine already that we have a completely
new game so let's see uh what's the idea
uh we have Pawn to A4 thread being Pawn
to A5 to trap the bishop on B6 and now
arat plays Pawn to E4 it's a pawn
sacrifice but it will sort of mess up
White's Pawn structure in the center and
you want to get uh some rapid developing
moves in so D captures on e4 accepting
the pawn and now Pawn to A5 stopping
Pawn to A5 from White B captures Knight
captures putting pressure on the bishop
here and Bishop to B5 check Pawn to C6
and Bishop back to E2 and now Reena just
castles Queen side and you get this
position where uh Reena is down a pawn
but uh he has all of his pieces already
developed the Rook is coming to E8 um
pretty much the last piece you have to
develop and the big question for Arjun
is can he Castle here and he decides
that yes he can he can Castle here and
even though there's quite a lot of stuff
here on the D file there's no uh good
way to capture the E4 Pawn right away so
you have to prepare it Rook hd8 but now
Arjun plays Pawn to E5 okay it's a
double attack but Queen to E6 uh this
pretty much forces a queen trade or you
could maybe keep the uh Queens uh in the
game by something like Knight to D4 or
maybe Queen to C2 Arjun decides that
it's uh uh definitely time to trade
queens now e captures on F6 we have
Queen captures on E2 Queen K captures
Rook captures and now F captures on G7
so if you count the material now Arjun
is just up two Pawns of course it's very
unlikely that he will be able to keep
the G7 Pawn so uh he will be up one Pawn
so what did Arena get for this uh early
Pawn sacrifice of his well he got the
semi-open G file to be used for his
Rooks and he has the bishop pair so that
uh we could say is a compensation in
itself we have Rook to G8 going after
the pawn and now Knight to D4 forcing
The Rook back we have Bishop um sorry
Rook e to E8 and now Bishop to A3 now
with some ideas maybe of Bishop to f8 to
keep the pawn H but of course Arena will
just capture it we have Rook F to E1
offering a rook trade and now Rook to d8
interestingly you want to go Rook to G8
but here it would just be premature
after Knight E4 going after Knight F6 uh
Bishop to H3 let's say you go after the
pawn just G3 and the Rooks aren't really
all that helpful on the G file so
instead we have Rook to d8 now the
Knight has to be careful otherwise this
Knight might hang on D2 uh Rook 8 to B1
putting pressure on the bishop and
Bishop to C7 uh we have Rook to E7 going
for a very nice Rook lift here and the
bishop to H3 sort of forcing Arjun to
advance the pawn to G3 which he does and
now Pawn to B6 uh we have Bishop to B4
uh and now Knight to B7 getting the
Knight into the game we have Knight to
C4 and here how do you continue uh this
position obviously by playing Knight to
C4 Arjun is inviting Pawn to C5 but what
is the idea behind Pawn to C5 from
White's perspective I will show it it's
a really cool line that uh was not
played in the game but you guys need to
know this because it um uh it is
required to calculate this very
precisely in order to understand rea's
next move so here uh if you play Pawn to
C5 the idea is Knight to B5 of course of
course you go after the bishop here then
The Rook will block you will play Knight
to A7 check and now wherever the King
goes you have a check on C6 so King to
B8 Knight to C6 with check and after
King to A8 there is Rook to E8 with
check you will of course block this with
Knight to d8 and now comes Knight
captures on B6 check you sacrifice a
piece here and after Bishop captures you
sacrifice another piece unfortunately
for black the second piece cannot be
accepted due to Rook to B8 Checkmate so
you have to play Bishop C7 to stop
Checkmate and get your Bishop out of
Harm's Way But now comes Bishop to E7
and this is how white wins this uh you
will now start collecting material for
example Rook G6 goes after the Knight
you will start capturing Bishop captures
on d8 Rook captures on C6 Bishop
captures and C7 with check from The Rook
of course King to A7 and now you will
move the bishop and the black king is is
in a very bad spot here it will uh it
will very likely get checkmated by the
two Rooks for example example if you
play Rook captures on C3 Bishop to E3
check and now if you move you get
checkmated uh so you will have to give
up the exchange here and the white will
now win this end game so that's the idea
behind Pawn to C5 right away so why
didn't C5 work well because of that
whole maneuver with u uh the Knight
coming all the way to Knight to B5
Knight to A7 Knight to C6 so what does
Reena do he plays Rook to G6 and it is
in fact the strongest move recommended
by the engine as it will prevent the
knight from accomplishing this maneuver
so okay Rook captures on F7 and now Pawn
to C5 now he does it so has The Rook uh
shifting to G6 really changed the
scenario uh let's see uh uh we have
Knight to B5 uh by by Arjun going for
the exact same line Rook to D7 blocking
and now Rook captures on D7 so you can
play this as the C6 sare is covered by
the by The Rook so that's not working
Rook captures on D7 Bishop captures on
D7 and now Bishop to A3 getting the
bishop out of Harm's Way and now Bishop
to E6 and interestingly here by playing
Bishop to E6 and move 31 arat blunders
the game away but Arjun doesn't pick up
on it what he did with Bishop E6 is not
just attack the Knight he also prevents
The Rook from uh defending the C6 Square
so now Knight to A7 is once again
winning uh point is that you will win
the B6 pawn it doesn't matter where you
go to if King to D7 dangerous kn
captures and B6 check right away Bishop
captures Rook captures you up two pawns
and the pass a pawn will easily decide
the game so that was in the position but
it seems that um he tricked him and
sometimes yeah you can very easily
Overlook such things you played Rook to
G6 on the previous move to guard the uh
C6 square and then immediately you play
Bishop to E6 preventing The Rook from
covering the C6 Square uh what are you
going to do chess is funny like that
sometimes so um Arjun just brings the
Knight back to E3 now comes Bishop to F4
puts the pressure on the Knight here as
the G Pawn of course cannot move uh
Bishop to C1 and now Knight to A5 uh we
have Knight to G2 attacking the bishop
Bishop back to B8 nicely controlling the
Knight here uh Bishop to F4 now offering
a trade of Bishops and the bishop to
B3 now the The Rook isn't very very
strong on the uh on the B file uh Bishop
captures on B8 King captures and now
Pawn to F4 so now you will have to start
worrying about arjun's past Pawn uh on
the king side and maybe or soon to be
past pawns so Bishop captures on A4
Arena minimizes the advantage to only a
one Pawn difference but now Pawn to F5
we have Rook to G8 now comes Knight to
E3 uh Rook to d8 and now Knight to A3
trying to activate the Knight but now
Bishop to B3 not allowing the Knight to
C4 Square King to F2 Arjun starts
bringing the king into the game King to
C7 now with we have King to F3 and King
to C6 both players just improving the
possessions of their Kings Pawn to G4
now and now if you give Arjun a few more
moves then the game is over so you have
to figure out how to play this Rook to
D2 Pawn to F6 and now King to D7 we have
Rook to E1 uh now if the king tries
approaching then you have all sorts of
nasty discoveries but just Rook captures
on H2 now the material is equal uh and
here we have Pawn to C4 Knight to F5 is
um is a better try
at a victory Arjun plays Pawn to C4 and
now he sort of lets um Arena back into
the game he we have Rook to A2 going
after the Knight Knight B5 and now
Knight captures on C4 so now uh reat for
the moment is up a pawn Knight captures
and C4 Bishop captures and Rook to E7
with check we have King to C6 and now
Knight to A7 with check uh we have King
to D6 and now Knight to C8 with check
forcing the King further back King to C6
and only now Rook captures on H7
equalizing in material so now we have
the past B and C Pawn versus the past f
and g Pawn uh who is faster and also
it's a knight against the bishop we have
Rook to A8 forcing the Knight to move
Knight E7 check King to D6 and now King
to F4 we have Pawn to B5 uh here
interestingly King to E6 is a must move
I'm I'm just going to show you why King
to E6 is a must uh because now if you
play Pawn to G5 you run into this um a
very unfortunate Rook to A4 move and the
King doesn't really uh have the option
of remaining uh on F4 uh there are just
you know two good discoveries here as
The Rook might be captured also it's
going to be easy to stop the pawns also
you cannot just start advancing as the
DF Pawn will fall so you play King F3
The Rook just follows you Rook A3 check
if you go here then even Bishop to G4
with check and the King will not be able
to escape checks if King F4 Rook to the
F3 check even and now if if you go here
you're under the mask of the bishop and
if you go here then Bishop D3 check
picks up the Rook you trade Rooks of
course captures captures but now the
pawns will not be able to advance and
it's an easy draw however after King to
F4 B5 was played and now there is one
huge difference here feel free to pause
the video and try to find the uh only
winning move for Arjun uh while I give
you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is night to F5 with
check G5 um pretty much U transposes
into the same line but Knight to F5
check U is just very forcing and there's
no way to avoid it the point is that now
King to E6 uh does not work because of
Rook to E7 check and now after King
captures on F6 there's G5 check King to
G6 and Knight to H4 with check King to
H5 and Rook to H7 will be Checkmate so
this is what Arjun found uh when he
played this Knight to F5 check move so
you have to move the king back King to
C6 and now just G5 now it's a race but
white got a couple of very valuable
moves in so Pawn to B4 Pawn to G6 and
pawn to B3 and now uh interestingly the
only winning move is Rook to H1 Arjun
hurries it up with Pawn to F7 but now
it's actually a draw Pawn to B2 Rook to
H1 and here B Bishop to A2 was played uh
probably of course reat saw that Bishop
captures on F7 is a draw I imagine he
also wanted to win this game uh to
quickly show why Bishop captures G
captures and Rook f8 you trade uh Bishop
for the two connected pawns and now you
will not be able to do anything with
this Pawn simply C4 and if King to E3
you're going to cut the king off and now
you have to give up the the queen in
order for the king to approach King to
D4 you'll play Rook to d8 with check
something King captures and now you you
will pick up this pawn and that's pretty
much it something like Rook h8 okay you
maybe paralyzed them a little bit King
B3 and now even B1 H with check you
force The Rook to move Rook captures
Knight and it's a draw uh by soon to be
maybe insufficient material uh but okay
Bishop to A2 was played I imagine reut
was still going for the win and now
comes King to E5 not G7 if G7 then again
Bishop captures on F7 is enough uh but
after King to E5 this is now a very very
important uh Square for the king point
being that if you play Bishop captures
on F7 now uh then G captures on F7 and
Rook f8 are M met with Knight to H6 and
now the king cannot get into the game
you have to play C4 King to D4 and the
pawns will not be uh posing any threat
to the white Rook or King so after King
E5 King to B5 was played trying to get
uh that pawn down the board uh but now
Knight to D6 with check King to B4 and
Knight to E8 also uh preventing the The
Rook from controlling the f8 square now
f8 is coming but now Bishop captures an
F7 G captures and now Rook to A1 uh
crazy crazy position uh so what do you
play here well Rook to H4 with check
let's prevent black from taking the free
rook first king to A5 only move that
still keeps black in the game and now f8
with check and now interestingly uh this
is still a draw but only if you find the
precise idea and it's not easy to to
find a precise idea here so just for fun
feel free to pause and do not lose this
game with black while I give you a
couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
being greedy for the queen and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
first one check is needed and to give
you an example why now after the king
moves you will bring the queen into the
game B1 Queen and now after white starts
checking you let say queen captures on
C5 uh it doesn't really do anything you
will block with the queen and that's it
you are perfectly fine and if you go for
Knight to D6 which is the original move
that was used in the game uh but not in
the proper move order then Queen to D3
check King to C6 Queen to A6 check King
to D5 and uh well it's just going to be
a draw by repetition The Rook nicely
cuts off the king from escaping anywhere
however in the game not hurried it up he
played B1 Queen right away and now with
the Rook stuck on A1 uh it's not really
the same here we have Knight to D6 and
there's just no good way now if you try
the same idea of Queen to E1 check uh
you can just block Rook to E4 and after
a couple more checks Queen G3 check King
to D5 Queen to D3 check King to C6 and
now Queen to A6 check you just Escape
via the D7 Square King A7 and now Queen
to King to E6 uh much much different
than if you had the Rook on E1 this
whole time so in the game Queen to B2
check was played now comes King E6 we
have Queen to E2 with check King to D7
and he was in this position un move 68
that Reena jumabay have resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here a few more moves and the black gets
checkmated it doesn't really matter what
you try you bring the Rook into the game
it's basically a mate in two queen d8
check only move King to A6 or King to B6
doesn't really matter but um or even
better Queen to d8 with check this
leaves only one square available to the
black king as the queen Knight and Rook
cover everything so once you move it now
Rook to A4 is Checkmate so I mean
everything wins but uh it's also very
easy to just win on the spot uh so yeah
very nicely done very very complicated
game it could have gone either way but
it was always Arjun who had um winning
chances uh and then in the end he he
took it he Reena gave him some three
chances and then in the end he had one
more opportunity but here it's so hard
not to bring the queen into the game
like play Rook e one first and uh okay
does come with check but still you know
it's a very hard hard to make a decision
like this uh but yeah I imagine reot
also wanted to win this game H and in
the end he lost it and the great win for
Arjun IGI who is now one of the leaders
of the tournament if you guys are
interested in the pairs for round six
here they are so and only players with
four points are Andre yeno hikaro
Nakamura and Ari yeno will be facing
Nakamura on board one Yu yangi will face
arigi on board two on board three Karana
will face Yi n then artmia Fu jaaku of
kimer vidit niman on board six savian
sarov PR shankland vashek Irvin Lami
who's having an incredible tournament
and one international Master even on the
first 10 boards International Master J
makov also from also from Kazakhstan
will be playing against Anish giri uh so
there we have it bit of an extra info
with the game I hope you enjoyed that uh
I would like to thank John gear Law
Office LLC Mario Milano the brers and
Spotify Steven mccan and chess better
than league for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day